I like attending isn't ashell
Assenmacher presents the v90 the luxury
station wagon becomes the third member
of ovals 90 family together with the
xc90 and s90 her first impression
elegant styling and no-nonsense
functionality the most striking design
feature is the vertical front
underscored with LED daytime running
lights the v90 is 4.9 meters long
providing plenty of room for passengers
the clear line running from front to
rear lens the car is slick form the rear
has a typical Volvo look with raised
taillights overall the V 90s design is
straightforward with no superficial
frills the trunk offers 560 litres of
storage space putting down the back
seats will up that figure to over 1500
liters thanks to the flat cargo bed
Michell remarks that despite its 235
kilowatts the v90 is no sports card
instead it glides down the road and
gives the driver a feeling of security
she tested the v9 tt6 with the most
powerful engine a four-cylinder unit
with direct fuel injection that propels
the almost two-time vehicle from 0 to
100 and 6.1 seconds top speed is 250
kilometers an hour
this version costs eighty one thousand
five hundred ninety euros in Germany the
interior is almost entirely digitally
equipped here behind the steering wheel
is a digital display of the instruments
and built into the central console is a
smart phone style tablet with various
apps but Michelle finds the overall
layout a bit confusing the v90 is
available in four versions with
different equipment packages but the
cabin is basically the same and all of
them buttons and switches have been
reduced to a minimum largely replaced by
a vertical 9.2 inch touchscreen at the
heart of the cabin is the infotainment
system the color combinations of the
various materials underscore the high
quality of the interior which is
spacious for both driver and passengers
the seats are economic and have plenty
of legroom
in Google's always have solid safety
setups as Michelle and the v90 has
plenty of them standard equipment
includes the city safety system with its
intersection braking assistant it
intervenes when oncoming traffic poses a
threat
the driver assists can be selected on
the touchscreen in the central console
or on the multifunction steering wheel
new is the pilot assist - for a semi
autonomous driving up to 130 kilometers
an hour the high proportion of boron
steel in the body translates into
excellent passive protection in an
accident the material is the sturdiest
kind of steel currently used to build
vehicles
the v90 is a true Volvo says Michelle
it's visual and technical modifications
provide a glimpse of the future of
driving a safer future with the Volvo
v90
thanks to driver assists and protective
mechanisms the v90 is an interesting
alternative and the luxury station wagon
segment